en este pequeño puerto de buyunbura Los
Pescadores regresan de una noche de
trabajo en el lago Tanganica
desobedeciendo la prohibición burunde y
la República democrática del Congo
sambia Y tanzania decidieron imponer un
período de descanso forzado durante tres
meses cada año para permitir que los
peces se reproduzcan solo pon cinco o
diez pescados para mis clientes vale
está bien los compro christoff un
revendedor depende de la pesca del día
para mantenerse
si cierran el lago no podré volver a
trabajar Me quedaré en casa porque si
viajo para venir acá tendré que gastar
dinero en transporte así que mejor me
quedo en casa
su salario pasará de alrededor de 10
euros diarios a cero a la población
local se le han ofrecido actividades
alternativas como la agricultura pero
christov teme lo peor ya que la
autoridad del Lago la organización
regional responsable del cierre no
ofrece ninguna compensación económica ya
tengo préstamos antes de pagar y
desafortunadamente con el cierre del
Lago no sé de dónde voy a sacar el
dinero para pagarlos creo que terminaré
en la cárcel algunas personas aquí
tendrán que robar para sobrevivir y
acabaran en la cárcel
estudios encargados por burundi la
República democrática del Congo tanzania
Islandia demuestran que los peces
empiezan a escasear estos tres meses de
respiro anual deberían contribuir a
multiplicar su población
como los científicos Lo propusieron
vamos a restaurar las poblaciones de
peces que están en pleno de equilibrio
las comunidades se beneficiarán
mejorarán su calidad de vida y el sector
pesquero será más productivo que antes
pero la sobrepesca no es la única
amenaza una parte de las aguas
residuales y los desechos de más de un
millón de burundeses que viven en la
capital
se vierten en el lago Tanganica es un
verdadero desastre al fue ministro de
medio ambiente y ahora hace campaña a
favor de la protección
no hay medidas de limpieza y saneamiento
bien establecidas Así que la gente pueda
arrojar cualquier cosa la cuneta y va
para el lago
los peces tienen que huir para encontrar
un ecosistema adecuado Y eso es una
pérdida económica pero también un
problema medioambiental economía
la mayor parte del agua que se utiliza
pero hoy por hoy el nivel de
contaminación es desconocido a fin de
vigilar y proteger el lago la Unión
Europea invierte casi 7 millones de
euros Para apoyar a la autoridad
encargada de gestionarlo
la posición la contaminación y la
sedimentación hacen que tengamos que
adentrarnos hasta tres kilómetros y
medio para poder encontrar agua bruta
que pueda ser utilizada para producir
agua potable
es posible encontrar desechos incluso a
varios kilómetros de las orillas estos
expertos están desplegando una sonda
para analizar la calidad del agua ahora
voy a esperar a que todos los parámetros
estabilicen antes de tomar las medidas
exactas aunque las aguas residuales y
los plásticos son los más visibles los
residuos agrícolas son la principal
amenaza a la biodiversidad
lo que más daña al lago primero está el
esparcimiento de abono en el campo
estos residuos suelen ser nocivos para
los seres vivos
cuando hay presencia de amoniaco por
ejemplo que procede de la descomposición
de la materia orgánica la descomposición
de la materia para los científicos y
ecologistas la capital económica de
burundi es un peligro para el medio
ambiente
es una ciudad que crece rápidamente y su
población se duplicará en los próximos
20 años
lo que significa que también se
duplicará el riesgo de contaminación
para el lago
en enero de 2023 las aguas residuales
provocaron una epidemia de cólera a
pesar de que la única estación
depuradora de aguas residuales está en
funcionamiento Esos son los camiones que
traen las aguas residuales recogidas en
los hogares la estación puede encargarse
del tratamiento y la distribución de
agua potable para un millón de personas
una capacidad considerable pero las
infraestructuras no siempre están
adecuadas es difícil conectar todos los
hogares de la ciudad porque hay
problemas de accesibilidad tenemos que
hacer muchas obras hay carreteras ya
construidas y tenemos que demolerlas
para conectar todos los hogares pero
esta estación ya puede tratar 40 mil
metros cúbicos al día
la lucha contra la sobre pesca y la
contaminación del lago Tanganica debe
llevar a una mejor protección de esta
inmensa reserva que contiene el 17% del
agua dulce superficial del mundo y
alrededor del cual viven casi 10
millones de personas